well it's great to see you here again
today at lidner film comic-con now
everyone wants me to ask you about
something you mentioned recently about
the five ish doctors reboot coming back
for a sequel so what can we expect
shoot me mouth off I only happened to
mention that in passing that when we
were in America recently Peter was there
I was there columnist Sylvester was
there and Peter got his camera out and
started doing it again essentially now
it may or may not come to anything now
it sounds like I'm trying to quash your
rumor I'm not because I know you know
he'd like to do something but it could
take months so there you go I know as
much as you do would you like to see
what would you like to the story to be
this time what in the farthest doctors
I've no idea but I do know one thing I'd
like to be in it because in the finest
doctors last year I was only I was
available for just one afternoon so
that's why I was away working in Ireland
and I was when I saw it I was a little
bit miffed that I wasn't in it more you
know
but yes so I'd like to be in it more I
want to see you back for that and also I
mean great cast wasn't there so many
people in it who would you like to see
it in this time what you mean like
Jackson all them yeah you know it was as
if I didn't know that was gonna happen
either it was clever I don't know just
heroes of mine maybe yeah
and I suppose it'd all be truly dead
radicals and World Cup winning football
players and things like that and Kenny
Dalglish yeah things he can he's ugly in
it
the five doctors in Kenny Dalglish
stager remember we heard efest but I'm
not trying to start a rumor all right
let's make it happen just make it happen
for me yeah and I'll be there that's do
you again that would be Peter Davidson
writing and directing I guess yeah it
would and he's I mean I think he did it
really really well last time you know
Anna and I know it took him eat them
similar things before only you know
there was tiny things he'd done before
so he's obviously getting better at it
and I know with the father's doctors
that the BBC of course laterally anyway
got involved and so there was more
doesn't it there may even have been a
little bit of money for it so whatever
happens it's going to be better than the
last time so what I mean is you know in
terms of the production I know more
money doesn't always know equal better
but he's got a chance you know yeah
now you mentioned also recently that you
wouldn't mind being Paul the Game of
Thrones world joining that cut yes you
did
they're all in today except they're here
today yesterday tell me what they got
their work cut up but that's that's just
everywhere in it that's its ubiquitous I
watched a few episodes of it though the
thing is with them when you I missed it
and whatever two three series of it
whatever it is
so to come in in the middle of something
like that's hard so I don't know what's
going on but nevertheless I know
everyone else that's in it I mean
everyone else I know seems to be in it
so I'd like to join in as well please
and get out there if you come in and I
don't you don't know it well but like
it's a world of kind of kind of set in
medieval ish times but in a fantasy
medieval medieval fantasy medieval you
know and there's a lot of murder
sex a lot of politics what kind of
character would you like to play in that
world kind of goody Abadi well look at
this face what would it be it would
probably be I wouldn't be an aging roue
right well no because that's like a
Charlie dance thing but what I'd
probably be is Nigel Havers but it would
have to be probably an impostor yeah all
my life was only working life I've seen
too with regularity it's got impostor
roles you know so probably an impostor
but like a you know a spy or if some
ambassador that ends up being the
murderer sort of thing or the one you
trust all the way through only to find
out at the end that he did it so they
must me there's a lot of crazy deaths in
Game of Thrones I don't know if you've
seen any of them in the in the episodes
you seem kind of that's why getting gold
poured on your head razor and when
someone dies in Game of Thrones they
always splash somebody else
it's them kind of that it's like they're
not content just to like croak there to
like pee all over the place smashing
their enemies ringo it's ruins and you
could have you and whatever death you
lights how you like to die in that crazy
way like to die like Socrates I would
yeah drinking the hemlock of my choice I
would
despite this yeah I would like just like
Socrates he's my hero services into the
five ish doctors reboot that's right I
know cuz they've already done it them
they were the Back to the Future they
are the circuit is in it that's what's
effective you know Bill and Ted they
were making their move it so crates they
met Socrates it's been done sadly you
mentioned Charles dancer so this is
rumor going around the Internet's at the
moment thanks Charles stars say is I
know it's crazy the Charles dance could
be the new master on Doctor Who
what you think about but I've never
heard what Charlie did it'd be great
he's a fantastic actor
and he's still got a twinkle you know I
don't know where he gets it from but
he's always at it I'm it's something
obviously you can't destroy that'd be a
good idea
I think the Masters never gonna go away
is he and rather like the doctor himself
you know because he is a you know he's a
Gallifreyan okay he's a Time Lord you
know it can take any guys so I suppose
you look like an aging roue from the
depths of space what do you think Joe so
let's do particular things of that role
of the master great gravitas
old-fashioned charm and and you are you
all nervous to remember Clifford the
dragon the others well then it's hard to
describe to you know it was an advert
for mouthwash
I think anyway it's too it's too
convoluted yeah charlie is Clifford the
dragon in my view he'll know what it
means well have you got a message for
your fans out there who want to see lots
more of you and everything but
particularly Doctor Who have I got a
message but the message is I sign the
petition as well so I'm right in there
where yeah so it will act here we had
Steven Moffat here yesterday and it was
a relief in one way it was great to have
Aamir but it was a relief that he was
here to field all those questions that
normally we get asked you know when's it
going out what do you is there any
secrets working till what can you tell
me about the future when you get a
spinoff and so Steven was you know
gently less and less gently as the thing
one trying to feel these questions so
now he knows so he's here so what's this
space did he say to people who ask you
those questions what he tended to say
that he didn't know because he hadn't
thought of it yet
and you can kind of appreciate it you
know he's and since he's the boss so and
he tends to be rather eleventh-hour with
most of what he says so anyway I mean I
said he was ignited a doctor it's gonna
happen tomorrow but I haven't written it
yet I'll write it tonight something so I
guess in that spirit if anything was
gonna happen with any one of us we would
know the week before so whenever you
hear about rumors and I hear there's
this room and it goes on for months and
months it can't be true because you know
if it's gonna happen it's gonna happen
quickly you know are you available yes
would you like to come we start Monday
that's how it works we look forward to
you getting that phone call Paul thanks
so much for talking to us again thank
you very much keep watching the skies
you